[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
summer of chess comes to an end
as 20 international grandmasters compete
in st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to round
3 of the 2019 ball chest classic as
always we are your hosts my name is
Caleb Denby and I'm joined by the
wonderful Grandmaster Dennis Boros oh
and we will be doing the coverage for
you today over these very exciting games
in the round 3 and today actually the
games got started an hour earlier than
normal there is a bit of a scheduling
conflict so a lot of the action is
already taking place so let's get into
the standings as quickly as possible see
where we stand coming into today in
group a fronting l cumin the sifter Bali
and Darrow's sweets are all tight at one
and a half points for first place darah
of course joining the previous two
leaders with a big win in round 2 over a
Rob s'en following them are Alexander
Linderman Jordan Vaughn Forrest vara
Cobian olexander bortnik and in last
place joint last place hey Sal exhibit
ah've ray Robson and Elias Miran with
just a half point out of 2 and in the B
group
what we have is Jack's tabbouleh AK out
to an early lead with a clear two out of
two to leave the turns on fire yeah
absolutely
however yes Turkish nada Perez is hoping
to cause some trouble for Jack he
actually already won his games so it'll
be interesting to see if if Jack
maintains his lead around mokou Guillen
is also at 1 and a half points
Stephan Zurich is one at one and a half
as well the chasers for Jack and then we
have a couple players at one point out
of to manuel Petrosyan and avec
Gregorian who have actually not drawn
any of their games thus far one win and
one loss for each of them then there are
a handful of players at 1/2 point and
poor Alex fear was 0 out of two so far
and why don't we take a quick look at
the format for this tournament and see
what these players are playing there of
course 210 player round robins that's
the a group in the B group the time
control for the tournament is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves then they get 30
minutes added on at move 40 for the
remainder of the game
there is a 30-second increment starting
from move 1 of course the players are
not allowed to offer each other a draw
until black makes his 30th move of
course they can also draw by repetition
or stalemate if somehow they get to
stalemate before move 30 well that's
pretty much all the setup for today you
guys are always welcome to join us on
social media follow us here on Twitter
use the hashtag fall chess classic to
get involved can join us on YouTube
we're keeping an eye on the YouTube chat
hello to all you lovely viewers silent
gamer unity 5 Zecharia Karen Rickey all
you know so many viewers today Denis
it's tough to say hello to the mom
pleased to hear that Karen is here yes
and lastly you can also follow the games
live yourself at u.s. chess champs calm
if you're interested in seeing all the
games seeing what's going on well
without further ado let's take a look at
the a pairings Alex epitaphs is paired
against Ray Robson today Alex Linderman
taking on Alexander bortnik Massif dura
bali is playing a tournament co-leader
current Malcolm Ian so that'll be an
interesting game interesting game to
watch as well watch yes you know Jordan
Vaughn Forrest drew his game already
against vara Cobian and then lastly our
key matchup of the day is daro spirits
one of those group a leaders paired
against chess legend Ilyas Mirren so
it'll be interesting to see how this one
shakes out with Darrow hoping to make
some advances in his bid for winning
this events and Ilya hoping to recovered
he had a very nice position yesterday
but was unable to convert it into a full
point unfortunately for Elias Mir and he
couldn't convert yeah but was very close
to winning again
you're done from forest and in fact this
tournament is turning into the war of
bananas the war of bananas so is that
what happened here today
exactly so smearin started off with c4
e6 cheats me c5 we actually saw this one
mm-hmm he played exactly the same thing
so he's being faithful to this system
right played this against received
arrived le verre the game continued and
later on massif came up with an idea and
one yeah game some serious opening prep
from from the c f-- in that game is but
I feel like it's it's important to note
note that uh it's not quite the same as
playing the Benoni against a move like
three nights e3 or three night f355 with
g3 white is committed to this feeding
keto variation which isn't quite as
testing as some of those other lines at
the Benoni but you might be surprised
because we've seen at least three
versions of the bony right the most
classical one that the c5 e takes C
takes d5 d6 allowing anything from right
to play even this Bishop f4 system which
is considered to bust the whole benoni
yeah that's certainly like one of the
most critical lines so this Knight f3
Bishop f4 systems and in fact stamboli
AK one with that exact system but coming
back to this game between spirits and
smearin we have this g3 system which is
supposed to make it okay for black to
play the benoni right because on the
highest level if he would ask an old
Soviet or Russian Grandmaster he'd raise
his hand and tell you no no no you shall
not play the benoni
an incorrect opening like that and
actually they say that because yes in
the long term you will have some extra
pawns on the queenside
right but your d6 pawn will be a
constant ekeus okay
so g6z 6 is happening goes against that
russian school to create instances for
yourself that's what you're trying to
say neither 3 castle castle rookie 8 so
but black is trying to achieve is to go
Knight e4 Nixon and opening up this dark
squared Bishop often if white goes a 494
indeed happens takes and sometimes even
this funky move of rugby for happens
yeah a pretty uncommon type of rook
lifts yes putting pressure and sometimes
even sacrificing the exchange which is
very interesting you'd expect this to be
bad for black but in fact these bishops
are so strong that there's ample counter
play make the computers would hate on it
and hate on me [ __ ]
I don't like that much but practice
shows that this is a game was trying out
it looks like an interesting line yes
sir rookie one was played planning to go
for in the future and also keeping this
pawn under protection because in the
future you can still go a3 which in the
horses I'm sitting on yes some some
peace let peace is landing on via or
whether it be a that rook or possibly in
this so 92 is an idea here here and then
now e4 and the point is that you want to
plant the knight on c4 and the bishop on
f4 and this is the dream scenario let's
say b6 night c4 let me make a random
move and after this this is the end for
black hat
this is strategically lost if white
manages to put both the knight on c4 and
the bishop on f4 this is completely
hopeless as eventually white will play
e5 and there's nothing you can do it's
never so easy though it's not that easy
but if that ever happens black can the
clear consciousness give up on this game
fair enough
so yes like has to play with some
urgency yes so benoni is a tricky system
it's not bad but you have to be on your
toes all
time not to mess it up okay a 497 again
94 was an idea here oh that is let me
correct that arrow trying to put it
there but he went for the 97 way of
playing 95 exchanging some pieces yeah
the the rule I've always heard is black
would love to change off at least one
set of minors he has enough squares for
kind of three minor pieces yeah so
you'll see black very often try
something like 94 or 95 yes to get rid
of that one set yes but the main issue
for black here for smearin is that you
might want to exchange some pieces but
you still don't want to get stuck in a
passive position of course because then
you'll suffer eternally yeah definitely
don't want unfavorable access and this
was a good exchange you want to free
your bishop or give it away if possible
right takes takes Bishop f4 h3 stopping
potential Knight h5 idea so you can drop
back to d2 and also getting rid of
Bishop g4 or Knight g4 s because
oftentimes this Knight would like to hop
to e5 and it would feel very comfortable
for let's say e4 Knight g4 is a typical
idea
preparing f5 and also planting this
knight on e5 and just to prove a point
sometimes you would go c4 here and the
idea is if this night lands on d3 it
will be a beautiful position for black
absolutely even if you would lose a pawn
you might still go 93 because it's worth
upon to open this glorious bishop up
yeah so h3 happened will be 8 a 5 and
this is the typical way of playing
against the banana you want to restrict
black yes now this is the moment when
you have to be vigilant with black
because if you allow Knight a 4 that
would stop let's say 8 6 9 a 4 this
would stop this b5 break eternally
sooner or later this will get very
uncommon yeah v5 the main way the black
yes counterplay so is a main source if
it's impossible then then it's going to
be very difficult for black to stop any
of White's ideas in the center yeah or
even on the queenside
just to show some basic ideas in these
structures if I've is not the only way
to play here the other ways to play will
be one and if b5 and you wanna meet it
with B for correct before correct and
you'll get somewhat surprisingly these
rule of best kind of structures where
black plays c4 but this just means that
white will get a free hand of doing some
active play my black is just condemned
of waiting and hoping for the best right
and if you would take this b5 would
become extremely weak and the dis d6
pawn becoming more and more visible
that's gonna be a big issue it's proving
the point of some some famous Russian
Grand Master's yes and that's why you
should listen to some famous Russian
grandmasters occasionally they know what
they're talking about yes a5 b5 and
Spearin knows what he's doing
takes takes and actually I know some
other Israeli grandmasters who are big
big experts on the benoni namely Lev
sakis who was a Soviet champion in the
80s right
in fact he tied with none other than to
get graped kim the great kim
gari-gari-kun
so he's a legend in his own right and
it's no wonder maybe that smearing got
inspired by his countryman
understandable so now usually the only
big issue here for white is this be to
pump so sooner or later white will go
broke a tomb and just defend it so e4 of
us played you want to defend this pawn
but White's play mostly revolves around
opening up the center with e5 yeah
especially with the the bishops planted
as they are kind of aiming at the
centers and the good part with this
fianchetto positions that this bishop
gives constant
protection for the d5 bond so if if I've
ever happens let's say age six again
just to prove a point okay not there's
some but it takes Bishop takes this
Bishop is dominating and if why Everett
manages to push the pawn to d6 this game
will end in White's favor the powerful
deep on really is the decisive factor
yes
so Knight age five getting ready to stop
that idea and also opening up the Bishop
Bishop III it's interesting I would
consider putting the bishop on d2
because that could potentially use the
fact and also looking for some tactics
and also maybe hep helping to eventually
play b4 right so Bishop III might be a
little inaccurate Bishop d7 r okay - as
it predicted it defends and you might
even actually jump on the a pawn you
know but is it a big deal if black loses
the a pawn okay well I think it's more
of the big deal that you allow White's
rooks into the business hmm so if white
word capture on a6 that means that this
rook on a6 is actually going to be
eyeing bikes real weakness which is of
course that that d6 pawn but sometimes
you can gamble it because yeah if Black
gets active enough you do get these
banker kind of positions and at that
moment I want to pay my respect for mr.
pawl banker yes he sadly just passed
away recently and some banker plans
still kind of work even in these
positions and as I showed that 95 c4
plan that's a typical banker plan yeah I
think what's more most important isn't
really a this a pawn or the b-pawn it's
that uh whichever side kind of breaks
through is going to be more active yeah
that's really well yes well we'll decide
the the fate of the the center even yeah
that's why it's kind of I kind of
assumed white is slightly better in
these positions right because white has
more space and can potentially start
pushing these pawns in fact the other
thing that I kind of a surprised not to
see is f5 probably
why smear and didn't play f5 this is a
typical typical benoni move yeah of
course but I guess he considers this a
bit too risky
yeah with white possibly even just
captures and then I think White's better
prepared to use this key file then black
would be and yeah there's these tactical
problems there's some weak squares in
the black camp so this always looks very
attractive for a black but if black
can't capitalize immediately there'd be
lots of weaknesses in his position the
the rule I've heard is that black
shouldn't really play f5 if white can
capture on f5 and still maintain control
of the e4 square and here black doesn't
have control over that square so it
looks like this should be favorable for
white yes and I kind of feel that this
should be the case case here yeah so
Queen b8 let's play probably that's why
smearing uses and tries to use this
pressure and saying that okay I won't
get that aggressive I'm okay with
sitting and waiting for you to decide
what you want to do sure and that's
actually the upside of playing the
Benoni your moves are fairly simple you
just want to put pressure on wide center
and it's easy to play although probably
your objectively worse
interesting so Queen b8 King gauge to
rugby for putting some pressure 91
protecting this pawn and now kind of
preparing this Bishop d2 move yeah also
of course the a6 pawn is now threatened
you know this be pond has been defended
yes Bishop b5 but to be honest with you
this Bishop didn't really come here to
defend it came here to go Bishop c4 and
get really active or potentially
exchanged this night off so the b2 pawn
can be taken it feels like black is
making some progress Nia's past few
moves
okay one Bishop b3 Roque for now getting
another pair of rooks off the board
takes takes Queen b6 and with more and
more exchanges blacks position is
getting more and more comfortable
because of this protected pass pawn this
actually might become a vice in the
future might become what the vice a vice
got it yes
so 93 hoping to either build some ghost
threats yeah why does it go to c4
starting to eye up these dark squares
around the black King Knight f6 yeah I
was kind of expecting even some like g4
g5 pushing a future for white yeah
although that's kind of a no-go at the
moment as yet naive Foursquare might
become a month earlier and also after
that typically you can go Bishop e5 and
then this night will be staying there
forever
ah and this is very sad for black well
if you play Bishop e5 for example in
this position I might be able to capture
it you might but I might even capture
with the deep on just to make sure that
yeah it's a strong night yeah that's uh
but alright yeah I'm usually the white
player in positions like these and if I
can ever force my opponent to play ad
takes me I'm usually very very happy
with my deep on yeah you're probably
right but because of this knight on f4
I'd still prefer in both cases and also
again another hail for the banker play
c4 again would come 93 right and I'd
rather be black yes fair enough this
Bishop is entombed just staring at all
those white poems tonight III was played
Knight f6 I think this is more it's not
that black cared about exchanging it's
like you want to put more pressure on e4
also getting rid of these ghost threats
yeah
Queen c1 you see one feels a little bit
too normal to my taste um yeah I'm not
sure I see the the tactical
justification behind that
easy for just hanging after we want
actually there might be some tactics
there takes and the ghost threats
actually become real oh no disaster
because let's say Queen f5 check boom
this looks this looks dangerous and this
is the end yes my friend I yes
no argument here so those threats are
good things and it sometimes it's useful
to defend against them because they
might become real yeah so what happened
in the game Age 5/5 so actually kind of
being worried about these GeForce top
also now Knight e4 would be possible
because there no Knight g4 tricks
anymore
right definitely so g4 as you predicted
takes takes Knight g4 and to be honest
when Black had to take on g4 bit denied
I kind of feel ok I think black did get
a decent kind of position you got a
fighting game and I'm not sure that
black is worth any more well yeah we saw
you know black kind of make this long
bishop maneuver over to b3 or the bishop
now stands a lot stronger than it stood
on yes I square like c8 or d7 and
there's this latent pressure on this
beep on on the B file
whereas White's plans have seemed have
faltered slightly right so not wonders
which was way more under in time he had
like seconds yeah vile smearing had like
20 30 minutes on the clock that's what
I'm telling you it's much easier to play
the black side for white you have to
come up with plans but it's not as easy
as it looks
yeah understandable so how did the games
on IG for takes takes Bishop d4 but it
turns out this is a bit too aggressive
in fact taking was good enough and
bringing the Queen back and after you do
that you have a potential a pawn not a
real so if the Queen actually enters on
AB 6 there's no real reason to fear mate
for black right so I would fancy blacks
chance and I would probably take black
in this position yeah interesting once
again I want to play this move g5 here
okay and really a lock down on that that
swear that you just might get out so
green e7 it's oh yeah I'll probably
eventually I think I have to play this
f4 move to control a5 I'll do it now I
guess actually York is a little bit
unprotected so I might just take you
okay so I'll start with Queen e3 I'll
start with Main Street
okay okay if I said Albert is my
favorite pawn mm-hmm I shall push it
push it real good interesting so I guess
what I was trying to say is you know why
can still try to find some counter play
in the game side eventually I want to
play something like rook h1 and king g1
and queen h3 and but this a pawn does
look it does look quite strong
well what I'm saying here that it's not
a huge threat so if I ever get my queen
on the long diagonal either through
Queen e5 or the store version I don't
see you checkmating me right so probably
Bishop takes was a better option as this
allowed a huge move for daro that he
actually missed yeah and and what was
that any ideas it's a spectacular move
okay I challenge you viewers to find it
all right
the viewers have been challenged I guess
I've been challenged as well you are
challenged as well my instinct just says
to play Queen h6 here but then maybe I'm
running into a lot of the same problems
that yes your instinct is like Darrow's
instinct because he did play Queen age
okay playing like daro not so bad for
not so bad not so bad it's a normal move
but there was a spectacular move
spectacular move that you just might
reject the rook III yes rookie 3 all
right
because if I still got something left in
me done yes so you get getting better
and better at puzzles Caleb yes
hopefully
so if takes nowhere to go but up takes
which you would never take if you're any
type of fianchetto player you would
never never let this Bishop do damage to
your king of course and it's not
surprising that after Queen age six I'm
gonna take all your pawns and mate you
fair enough
so rookies we would have been like a
huge move and because of potential
attacks on b3 which is a rarity usually
this Bishop is on d7 my twins just
enough Tempe to go broke h3 let's say c4
rook age three rookie five but that's
not helping you because I'm gonna chase
you away and it check me in on AJ
interesting and I guess this also points
out the difference between playing a
move like rook h1 overlook III yes with
Rick h1 you can get the rook on the edge
file but then you have to put this King
on to the uncomfortable G 1 square in
order to open it up yeah and then that
doesn't give you these options like f4
yeah
and rookie 3 is that typical move that
table would make no heartbeat he'd say
okay how can I then immediately right
Karpov would play Queen h6 because he
says okay I'm not sure and I wouldn't
start thinking that I should be winning
here yet but there's an optimist like
tall Brook III would be just expected to
help them
okay so pj6 we played it's not a bad
move but it's kind of a shame not to see
you Brooke e3 on the board you need six
takes I mean green d8 g5 v 7 Ben F 8 and
this is the maneuver I was saying that
the Queen will eventually find its way
to the long diagonal and it's going to
be fine for black right okay one takes
Bishop c4 and this time because the pawn
is not
not only a fourth defended on with the
bishop on b3 this fond structure is
still kind of uncomfortable for black so
there is still a hope for an advantage
for white here there's some fluidity for
right there's maybe I'm going to play e5
maybe I'm going to play f5 depending on
YES on the circumstance and it's not a
big deal if you go f5 because I can't
really do much with the e5 square yeah
if I put my King there I mean the rook
there that doesn't really do anything
special you can imagine something like
white playing f5 and then f6 and all of
a sudden there's some very serious
threats against the black king again
but I feel objectively this should be
fine for black because this a pawn can
become strong if needed and there is
some pressure on e4 maybe Bishop d3 is a
move right potentially and with the King
so close to this pawn and it's probably
going to be able to stop a d6 d7 push if
e5 ever happens and so this is the
current position yes this is the current
pizzelle let me update update there
Brooke d3 was Bishop d3 was played okay
for and c4 was played interesting so I
guess we should you know let the players
continue working on this end game why
don't we take a quick look at the B
pairings and then I think we actually
have some exciting news in that key
matchup there at the bottom which we
will talk about shortly yeah so Manuel
petrosyan was paired against Steven
Zurich Denis Kendrick has drawn his game
against Victor Michalowski Iran poco
bian is paired against Alexander fear
yes sir Quesada Perez won his game
against Amon Hamilton catapulting him
into the clear second place behind
Jackson Bulli AK and then Jack continues
to get it done in our key matchup of the
day against a veteran gorian he actually
has already won this game putting him at
an astounding three out of three once
again going to be clear first ahead of
his competitors and I think we actually
have Jack ready to come in and talk to
us about his game so why don't we take a
look at his game and get him in the
studio Dennis all right then guess what
opening was it yes
so this is the day of the benoni but
maybe not a field day for the Benoni
he's six takes takes d6 and as Caleb
already mentioned this is not the best
version ever because white is not forced
to go g3 Bishop g2 can play this was the
old mainline efore was the old mainline
say g6 Bishop d3 Bishop g7 Knight f3
castles h3 and there were many many
fantastic games would be 5 and but why
it was usually slightly better but
actually we have Jack here hello hello
so were you surprised to see Benoni
today kind of enough yeah I was more
expecting with Kings Indian mm-hmm
really prepared for a banana mm-hmm but
anyways take 6 d6 were you considering
any other moves apart from going for the
most principled Bishop f4 no I mean it
was like the only one that I waited yeah
I just mentioned to caleb early on that
all the soviet grandmasters and Russian
grandmasters would say go Knight f3
Bishop f4 and the benoni is done
Bishop f4 a6 that's all the times people
go a for yeah a for is the main line
here like had some ideas opportunity for
mm-hmm so II for b5 that's the most
principled way as far as I have or maybe
sometimes there's not h5 stuff I've seen
Judit Polgar play something like that
yeah b5 Bishop e2
'if I've if I feel and here it was very
interesting like late night age five
because I didn't know this morph like I
just knew if like if you take only five
I take with a night and this position is
with a good advantage for wine I guess
you get your Bishop there
yeah and start pushing and this is just
a joyride
yeah knowledge fact was very interesting
and I guess I didn't play well here
after night age five and one Bishop III
was which was the most natural movement
but I guess Bishop g5 was better and
still the position is pretty complicated
after Bishop g5 because there is a six
and maybe like Bishop h4 should age for
ya as an interesting move but here black
should be fine I guess again takes
Knight e5 Knight of four and there's
some threats and this Knight is pretty
strong there yeah so you played Bishop
III which looks like a very normal move
yeah but apparently here black is
completely fine so he took 25 and Bishop
c5 locate and here I wasn't sure what to
do it cuz in your shoulder I saw that
after get six I would have a good
advantage but then after I started
calculating it wasn't clear for me what
to do after let's say like 97 I thought
if I go before some Bishop d7 and it's
not very clear I'm gonna appreciate
cousin neither 4s pretty annoying the
rook c8 and everything starts hanging so
it's yeah this looks actually very
comfortable for black
yeah cuz your pawn is blocked
comfortably with the knight on these
seven it's an ID so what was the idea
behind idea 292 I'm not sure about this
most probabilities it's like a bad move
the idea was to put the knight on e4 and
then to g 6m
yeah but Zana after 97 Bishop e3 didn't
release tonight up sticks a subnet
Knight of 6 was not possible because of
Knight e4 but then after he played
Knight of 6 I realized that there's
before and like so I cannot play it and
then like I have to exchange an m6 and
my d5 pawn will fall
I see so you played pin B 3 defending
cesarean pawn Knight b6 is getting a
little uncomfortable because they're
encircling your pawn bishop f3 594 yeah
your fork only for you take here it was
a very interesting moment he got two
choices big he played Bishop takes e4
but instead he could have played night
c4 which is very interesting and after a
bishop takes f5 she takes a 5 I thought
a for Ruby it it takes d5 it takes d5
and I was considering ok 6 and I thought
that my position is fine here and like a
forest Bishop c1 but then I checked it
to his computer and it says that the
black is better here yeah I was like
well I mean I would agree with you that
practically you still have a decent
position and a chance to push this pawn
so it might not be that simple
yeah so Bishop e3 Bishop takes e4 excuse
me happen ethics Bishop takes this was a
very good move getting rid of that
active beast
yes which was about to hop to c4 yeah
cuz they'll here's another problem is
that I cannot take on e4 because he has
Queen takes d5 against and if I take on
b6 q takes on e4 yeah there's also a
nice little tactic here because e4
Knight is hanging so white would lose a
pawn okay so Queen b6 94 and suddenly d6
is a real threat now yeah but still his
position is pretty nice from here and he
played very well I seen him play 24 rook
e1 will be e d8 and then Quincy 4y and
here in this position I considered to
move like Queen f3 is some of whatever
like that I played and also another move
was g4 84 interesting yeah G forces idea
is to kind of get this lock post on
before so they used to play g5 but here
I wasn't really sure if it's like good
enough
like after a queen takes disarray take
the three I wasn't really sure about the
same game because let's say he plays f6
and he cuz like king king of salmon
Bishop afraid a five idea
so like might get double-edged so like I
didn't want to go for this yeah you're
right this does look edge B but also
this g4 move is very super interesting
usually you don't play a G for when the
Queen's are still on board
actually that kind of makes me wonder if
Queen C is an idea probably not because
it's just go aged yeah and then the same
thing d6 okay so you sack the pawn and
he said let's go six and I suppose it
like I cannot be worse here because my
pawn is very strong but then apparently
I mean he played very well and so at
some point he he could have just got
almost winning position like win g3 was
a mistake apparently but I didn't really
see his idea I thought like after Queen
g3 if he takes on Jesus won't be too I
go g7 and here I didn't see Bishop
before but the shop d4 is a very strong
move here and after Bishop before I
guess it wasn't and we both didn't see
this more so rue Casey it was played and
you're taking what was just a blunder
yeah because now this night is
stationing there forever
yeah you'll skip play to like very well
and here I just got watching because
after appreciated before like the
position is almost waiting for me the
Queen f7 d7 and this is very
uncomfortable especially that this rook
is going to get harassed very soon yeah
but later in the game she still had some
chances rook c6 would be six at for
Queen g4 and this is a very nice little
Intermezzo just giving away the rook
understand this pawn would be very very
strong Bishop f6 in f4
ship c3 yeah Bishop sister is a very
nice trick
well I guess if there is no Bishop
sister he's probably losing and I cannot
trade Queens because his King will get
closer to the D pawn so like if I take
one of seven he just takes I take so it
when six he takes only one and then
before his hanging and I cannot really
promote the phone because he has King g7
more yeah and you might actually stone
getting into slight trouble maybe but
your pieces are so active that shouldn't
be a problem
yeah that's why I decided to go Queen h4
and here he could have survived like if
you took on d6 like he took anyone which
was a mistake
yeah but if he went for this line here
after rook F one she has Bishop before
so now I have to promote the Queen so
like mini eight let's say Oh Queen c7
yeah and after he takes on c5 I promote
the Queen with tray 28 and this position
is not clear at all like it's very SS
it's like playing for three results here
so unfortunately for Gregorian he went
for ship take C 1 but this it was just
losing ya weeks a 6 and actually like I
didn't see the Queen D it was a much
easier because I didn't see a 96 Janna
but it was yeah completely winning
because I started after Queen d8 there
was a very nice line who in d8 King just
7 and I didn't see 96 of course 996 is
winning but then I thought Queen up 6
well here here but here Queen f6 he
takes take rock up six d8 Queen and then
he takes the bishop takes after they
take son of two E and here it's not easy
at all like if I go like king h1 let's
say he takes on c5 and this is yeah and
there's a checkmate so if you would
check at block yeah that's very nice so
here he's fine
so rook takes c6 was maybe the best
technical move because Queen D could get
murky not that in a practical game you
can sense that it's plus 15 so rook they
c6 Ruka fate will get bigger it's a nice
finish as takes takes X nu promotes but
it's a check so there's no Bishop f2 so
yeah so three out of three on a roll
the tournament is going really well for
me
you got to better like it today but I
mean meet your fought fell you found
some good counter chances how are you
feeling feeling good I'm gonna prepare
for the next game
all right well best of luck for the next
round and go four out of four let's sink
it all right so let's take another peek
back to the a group game between smearin
and daughter spirits so they've been
some developments there we left it
around here okay for was played
defending this pawn rook b8 so you can
see the theme black is trying to get
active in the Benoni and Spearin knows
that c4 okay eight and this might look
strange to you at first sight but the
point is that black wants to chase this
rook away and then start pushing the
pawn so this is just temporarily bad
yeah once again I just want to say a big
congratulations rejection but yeah it
says playing very impressive chess the
sig result and a very nice finish in
today's game we have six was very
stylish yeah impressive tactics an
impressive calculation to you know
somehow it's always easier to find your
opponent's ideas rather than your own
but he seemed to really have a good
handle on the line actually I was more
impressed with his g4 move which I think
was a very aggressive positional move
yet you think it would be like tactical
but it was more like stabilizing the
knight on e4 yeah a lot of understanding
oh you were talking about this engine so
ya so King f2 a5 and as I'm saying
smearin predicted that he will be able
to start pushing that pawn and this is a
dream come true for a benoni player that
actually you get to push your a and C
pawn which doesn't usually happen you
usually use in twenty five moves and you
cry why you played the opening yeah
first place I can definitely relate to
to just being super happy once there I
reach some like equal a shine game
playing the Carroll Khan myself that's
often the dream and now why did play e5
but it's a different ballgame as the
king is in the center just a block I
felt like a lot of whites pressure was
coming from the fact that it was a
little unclear if the black King was
going to be able to contribute or not
yeah the black King originally in the
middle game was under some slight
pressure yeah and as we mentioned that
rookie three move would have put
smearing in a top spot but in this end
game I actually fancy Ilyas Mirren's
chances and my prediction is that with
26 minutes against 10 the legend might
strike it could happen one question I
have here is yes okay can we just play a
cage one and say a cage one you're not
going to invade on this h-file and I
don't see how you're gonna make progress
maybe I go the other side trying maybe
to go look see and attack the c4 pawn
yeah that's fair enough
I'll just maneuver my bishop I'll play
Bishop let's say e 4 rather than f3 you
see let me try a 3 okay you're coming
quite quickly yes this pawn is right
right quick so if you would go Ruby when
I say a 2 and some questions am i able
to play rec a 1 though you do you do I
play a to Bishop c2 is my idea to see -
ok don't probably you survive yeah
thanks
Ruby for and I have em both play with
black so I'm not in danger cuz anytime
you move to go here I can check you and
if I start taking stuff yeah I agree I'm
not trying to win with white here but I
think that this this might be a very
forcing line to go down because if black
doesn't go for this then I don't see how
he's going to make any progress actually
I wanted to show this move that the
engine showed and the engine wants to
play Bishop e1 is this is the cutest
move I've ever seen of course of course
you would put your Bishop unfree on b1
by how else are you supposed to attack a
- yes exactly this
be one the bishop moves diagonally so
it's kind of hilarious that this Bishop
cannot move and it's dead there
the bishop Biman there's a real star
move yes taking advantage and it takes
which would be the natural way to punish
white you can take on a two and you can
go rotate because I would take your
bishop
yes so sing stuff they're still thinking
at this position switch is thinking
whether he should go rook h1 or not I'm
not sure what his other option is he has
to find some way to find counterplay if
he doesn't stop black from invading and
I don't know where that would come from
yes and but I do think that smearin is
calling the shots and he has chances of
actually winning the game it could be
maybe what dar was thinking is Rick h2
isn't actually that big of a threat
what if white just plays like rook e1
and then uh are you really going to come
in to h2 yes I attempt to okay I'll
simply play ricky to was my original
idea rookie to let me attack your pawns
are you getting anywhere though Rick F -
I guess - and now you're going to take
and now I think you're C pond yes it's
very sad yes well that's why I wanted to
play Yorick h1 darou has other ideas
with something else and it looks like
the players have agreed to a draw
interesting so probably they kind of
assumed that Luke H want wrote back and
they'll repeat forever right so I'm I
would have thought that Elias Marin
should have pushed a little bit more not
that the position is an objectively
drawn but if we look at the position
it's clearly black who's calling the
shots all right so I think lunderman is
actually looking quite good at his game
if we let check that out in the a group
let me see
so Linderman has quite a strong passer
there I had a powerful beep on yes and
that night isn't really doing much but
actually let's go back see this position
for a second so it was a typical for the
door where white took on the 8 right
King takes the 8 and it's kind of funny
I had this position with black yes
against none other than a guy named
Wesley Wesley oh I know a couple chess
players named Wesley exactly
so that mess lee whom I suppose all of
you are familiar played this against me
and here Lenderman found Wesley's
maneuver what he played against me and
it's kind of interesting because you'd
think that black is ok you have the
majority here and if you get to exchange
this bishop or the c3 one you'd have a
good time
yeah but should be six a very natural
move yes however however this Knight d2
maneuver jumping on c5 so the big
problem with this King on the 8th is
that you can only go to e7 because you
already moved the King to d8 so it can
only go forward and Castle that's
illegal and if the knight jumps to let's
say c5 any check will be deadly yeah
definitely don't want to end up with
your king pinned to the back rank in a
situation like this this is practically
lost because you cannot really develop
your pieces anymore
you can already go f4 f5 j-just just
break it open in the center the white
rooks are perfectly placed and the black
rooks are confined to the wings yes
so a4 was played saying no no no no no
you're not going to be three yes
but then again another vestnik plan that
he again played against me and that was
the first time I was really
impressed with a player yes is this a
three preparing night a two to be four
yes that is very very closed to the plan
or that maybe c4 as well yes and c4 and
then things just collapse this isn't a
this is a maneuver that you see on the
kingside sometimes yes in order to
remove a powerful defender on f6 white
will play h3 and these efore e5 lines
and the knight h2 to g4 to take off that
piece but it's interesting to see it in
effect on the Queen side that's not
something that's very normal to me an
actually 92 is such a high-class move
because it prepares to attack the c6
spawn and this is why you need to show
your Buddhist side when playing chess
yes
you don't necessarily play a move on
tempo you kind of wonder what is the
weakness in my opponent's camp what if
it's the c6 pawn how can I reach it well
bring let's bring the night over there
very straightforward chess but it's a
very difficult to stop as well but it's
a deep chest in a deep way of playing
this game
96 c4 a bit more cave Manesh c4 is a bit
more cave managed yes
what I meant to say was logical chest
yeah right were the same purpose yes
it's more of logic chess it's not brute
force yeah so Bishop d7
but when Linderman's sees big weakness
he bounces at it and now the night goes
back and decides that this bond is the
weakness now so I'm going there
interesting rook b8 Knight f3 and it
says hello to the d7 Bishop and this
King is still stuck in the center
suffering and the big problem is that
Knight d5 might come and that will be
the beginning of the end yet again I did
want to mention you said 9a2 and this is
really high-class chest and we're not
sure it's is that's the sentence that's
ever been said before Dennis I think
that might be original to you okay
anyone has ever described okay copyright
hi clan hi class yes
hi class move copyright by me I heard it
here so b4 and this is kind of sine of a
desk
raishin take sakes 95 and the problem is
just like in the Benoni it was easier
for what for black to play chess right
it's so much easier to play this with
white because all your moves are just so
logical and that that is why I praise my
day into so much because after that move
it's all of the moves are just just easy
right and meanwhile black is kind of I
think floundering a little bit yeah he
said some desperation here yes
Bishop a6 look at all these Lenderman
happy moves yes Ruby a takes Bishop c4
and these moves might not be the
objectively best but they are easy he
says I have the bishop pair you have a
weakness just putting his pieces on good
squares what is there to complain about
here for white nothing does you take the
pawn King g7 let's liquidate I'm up a
pawn I have the bishop pair
there's no way things could go wrong so
let's fast forward a bit more exchanges
the measurement is a good technical
player he never rejects the option of
exchanging stuff when he's up material
Bishop c6 but one thing for sure he
knows he wants to keep his Bishop right
because a rook endgame might get Josh
Tom yet there's also tactics going on
here right if Knight takes something
like I don't know yeah g hiri and the
Knight takes d5 then ah
oh yeah well most active as well
controls g2 yes but a tactic for black
would be of g3 there's a Knight takes d5
and this rook check picks up the bomb
yes and g g3 instead
so if g3 then takes and you pick up the
pawn but in any case why go for that I'm
gay yeah just keep you bunch of five
Kings c3 and this is again good
technique you defend all your pieces why
give you false hope to your opponent
what beats me checking c4 and ermine
knows that the king is the strongest
piece and
endgame and then he says Bob push it all
the way home
let's go yes Bob you have one job and
that is to promote 9 F 4 B 5
even the pawns are equal now nothing
equals Bob no I take I take Bob over all
three of the kingside pawns
all hail Bob okay okay one rugby two and
now Bob is getting stronger by the hour
Bob's your uncle Dennis yeah Bob's your
uncle King bee five five takes and sadly
when things go wrong they go horribly
wrong yes you can't even live in a piece
when it's given through you for free
when it rains it pours this day six
rookie - he says Alex says nope pass
along you can't get through anymore just
showing all the friends that I know King
these six these grand masters are very
mean when they're winning in a night yes
yeah I know you're King it's over there
yeah it was too close swim further away
your knight you can't move that guy
either and probably the end is nigh as
alex is about to capture that guy on the
8th and then bob does the dirty work
promotes and then bortnik is probably
gonna resign pretty soon and yet if we
move like rookie - there's simply king
c74 yes right just defending this pawn
no hope of a rook and Bishop person yeah
no no no no to the idea of a rook and
Bishop is King c7 and now after taking
this night Bob as we said just does the
business yes all right so let's say a
big win for Alex yeah that does that
take a look
how would Lenderman do after a potential
win here so that brings him actually to
2 out of 3 so he would be definitely in
contention for this leading position in
the group name alack alex is beaching to
play the killer move of king c7 and
it's on the board we see and bortnik is
about to say bye-bye to this game I
guess yeah well why don't we take a
quick look at the der Bali game I can
smell cumin because those are the two of
the leaders in Group A so if either of
these players can win
I think they move into Seoul first in
Group A so in this game their belly has
a nice little pony on d5 very nice pony
a bit nicer than the counterpart it like
naive only five is not that bad but this
dude can jump around to e6 attacking a
real weakness now you'd say but what
about this pawn isn't that a weakness
well not if it's covered up by a knight
on d5 right and with the knight on e6
it's also very difficult to get a rook
to the D file yes so as I say it's it's
only a weakness if your opponent can
attack it yes so probably a good plan is
to bring this rook over for this night
to go back we can do it maybe oh no
because King III was just played I also
like to move like to move that's not
good news for black that's a good news
for black but I don't see how I can stop
white from coming up with a long-term
plan yeah for example you might start
with King II or well I'm sorry King III
was just played yes let's see why white
took c6 the time to do this rather than
just playing out of 46 immediately well
this is again the way to play chess
slowly steadily if you have the
advantage no rush okay you can always go
night at 496 all right you can do it any
time how many right now but okay okay
we'll bring the rook to the seat file
yeah and this looks fairly glorious for
white and you don't really want to go
see four because you might build a
Center for white and if I can start
rolling my enf bonds yeah it's going to
be the end it's also worth noting this
pawn on g7 is another major weakness and
we just heard that Alex just won his
game yeah
no surprises there so this brings Alex
to two out of three as we said so he's
now tied with daro
for a first place and it really all
comes down to this last game durable
email kuhnian here to determine who the
leaders will be in group a so let's take
a look at Ray Robinson's game as he's
trying to bounce back
Absalon earlier on yes so Brooks c6 it's
interesting that every game we look at
the king is boxed in yes
again this time it's White's King that's
box in in the corner
well if black isn't careful he'll find
his King in a pretty tight box of
checkmate yeah this would be also a
tight spot for this guy yes because you
can't really go anywhere so they said
okay I'll defend that pawn very
responsible but in pawn rook and pawn
games you want to be with the more
active pawns yet more active pawns and
the more likely well and just looking at
this position you'd say I want to be but
black I definitely agree here so g5h for
hoping that something would happen but
because of this unfortunate placement of
this King h5 would never work because
you almost get checkmated by losing all
your assets quite difficult so rook
takes c3 Brooksie to rook f3 again you
had your last chance of running away but
no more back in your box Zac in the box
and now this King is like a men in the
Box once again grandmasters they're
quite mean to each other
yes end games they're pretty mean but
sometimes gracious they do play the Ben
Oni time to time
very generous stuff yes rook apps to
hoping to get this King out of it but
mine is already down upon
so Robson says that's fine with me he
just takes anything here foreign
activating the king so he's happy to
exchange this pawn for these two as a
connected pass pawn is a theoretical win
yeah I wanted to mention not only is
white down upon
but the fact that a black spawns are all
connected like this makes advancing the
black pawns quite easy and advancing the
white pawns is going to be quite
difficult especially with the king stuck
on the second rank here it will be five
and this cluster of pawns are very very
hard to stop as they're going to invade
White's position like they're the Borg
yes and just tactically it thinks it
seems like things aren't working out for
white yes
you can't play something like wreck of
fate King G for Ricky it because I will
once again be taking both of your Kings
side pockets and you only get one of
mine yes
so what caleb is talking about is this
line and it doesn't matter that my king
is far away because you can't ever take
this pawn because this e pawn will make
a run for it
connected pastors are almost always get
enough actually that's what happened
rook f8 must play King g4 Robson is
having an afternoon meal on the kingside
at 6:00 King age 5 I'll let you wrap up
your thoughts on this game I believe we
actually have Alexander Lenderman in to
talk about never win and grew marvelous
probably launched again into the leader
position so big big win for Alex so this
will be a big thing for me because most
of the time I get interviewed by Alex
Slenderman and this time it's payback
time so in this position this is just
great for Ray because these funds are
just unstoppable meanwhile we have Alex
setting up so I do think that these
pawns are just way too strong there's no
way for white to survive this but
meanwhile we have Alex Slenderman here
with us how things to see you here on
the other side Thank You Dennis see I
remember I was interviewing you most of
the time when you were you know winning
some
the games at the normal tournament
treatment yes so can you get us through
the key points of your game it was very
nice actually it was very impressed with
your night maneuvers um well I think I
played pretty decently in opening I
think I got a very promising position
right away I mean I was a little bit
surprised with a few early opening
choices he made in my preparations so I
had my preparation if it wasn't as deep
as out as I would like but then somehow
quickly my position became very good and
I think my position was more or less
winning at some point but then I'm quite
embarrassed about my technique did you
expect to fill the door to show up I was
more expecting the move 97 here because
that's what the move he more often plays
and I figured the main reason he does 97
more often is because he doesn't like a
5d 65 otherwise there is no other
necessarily reasonable explanation to
play 97 you know because y can also just
go a night of pre transposing 3-5 so I
figure he probably doesn't like the end
game so I prepared the end game in that
case that he does that and deep chest
psychology in the works so d takes e5
takes takes and actually you brought up
some painful memories for me because I
played this with black against Wesley so
and I vividly recall 92-93 maneuvers
yeah and it's did you know about that
game oh I saw some sample games that I
liked us even the white side just in
case he actually does go into this
actually even after Bishop c4 I'm more
expected but should be 6 from him but of
course I looked at some games with King
e8 and I figure ok it's slightly more
pleasant than probably he's a tactical
players so you know get an endgame like
that he'll be comfortable and you get
the young guy in the end game should be
even well I mean he's a very experienced
player I mean I I'm joking no it wasn't
it wasn't that easier but somehow it
seemed like my position became very good
very quickly
not sure exactly where he went wrong but
I'm guessing this will be fives probably
okay but I'm guessing this whole a5 a4
thing probably is a bit too ambitious
although I'm not sure maybe I'm slightly
better here anyway but I mean the
critical moment was can you play before
but I didn't think he can because Knight
a for Knight takes e4 and I have many
moves I thought ninety two's big
compensation also Bishop d4 is very
interesting you know the pointers he
can't Castle right that's the important
thing too I remember hitting that in my
game against best leader right and also
Jing is just terrible on the eighth if
you can't cancel yeah exactly that's why
I wanted to open up the game because you
know I always knew that it's kind of a
problem for block a long term problems
so no I know it's not roses for him but
I I'm still surprised how good my
position became so quickly yeah actually
that's why I was so impressed when I
played that game I thought that this is
fine for black 5 moves later I can't
move
yeah no I guess no it's not so easy
apparently yeah I mean it seems like it
should be close to equal 4 block but
somehow yeah you have to be very precise
yeah and actually I really loved your 92
move
oh you know I was I was considering
instead of Knight of 8 I don't know how
good it is but I was considering which
things b5 quite seriously a whole line
of fate huh
Bishop takes B 5 CB 5 95 and then I
either 96 or Bishop b8 and then I go
Knight c4 and I thought this could also
be you know compensation but I just
thought after Knight a to I'm still
better so I didn't see a reason to go
for it but I'm just wondering you know
whether oh I hope it wasn't like
crushing or anything but it wasn't but
definitely I really liked this move
because you're Iying all these
weaknesses it's kind of nice
alright so take me to the key moments
here yeah so yeah Knight of three was
important because if I start with 95 he
goes Bishop a5 and Thwaites I'm still
probably better but it's not so easy
tonight if there is an important move
building my harmony and kind of
tightened down to a 5 point and now I
guess its position is already difficult
but it looks like he made the blunder
before takes rook takes a knight
five and I think here I thought I'm just
completely winning and no maybe for a
second my brain relaxed because okay he
found a good defense rugby rugby seven
breaking news fear won his first game so
the Benoni this time strikes
so I actually equalizes the score Benoni
is still back on the plate yeah yeah so
Ruby seven so back to the game yeah Ruby
seven Bishop a6
Ruby eight so now he wants after ninety
seven that my bishop hangs yeah and so I
took took the ship c4 and I thought okay
I'm winning a porn and he still can't
castle and I thought I'm just up a porn
with a much better game and more or less
winning but here to his credit he found
some good moves 96 controlling the c5
square and after 95 King D 7 king e7 and
here I was spending forever trying to
figure out like really something knock
out or really you know consolidate like
a really easy technical position I
couldn't do it I couldn't find though
did you consider here I'm curious what
were the consular dating moves you were
thinking of well I was considering this
she takes his six quite deeply you know
King takes c6 and and I was trying to
see if you know moves like a 493 would
lead to anything special but I yeah what
drag does get really active yeah yeah
yeah I saw it seemed not so clear and
him it was a very committed move then I
also considered of course Knight takes
d7 I considered a for right away and the
problem is if I play you can play rook
c8 but should be a 10 so it was I
probably missed something I'm sure I had
could have played much better like
around like next couple of moves or so
because I feel like my position probably
was more or less winning but then I made
it make a very difficult technical task
and I think at some point you know it
was it seemed unclear to me I mean if
I'm even better mhm
so was uh yeah it's interesting because
suddenly you you found yourself up upon
in an opposite side castle in game and
so yeah I was wondering now maybe this
whole idea of Bishop h6 maybe wasn't
best maybe I should have done something
else but you know still it feels like
something should be where
stronger I I just I was looking forever
I couldn't find it but I still kind of
like this right here is still exchanging
off pieces yeah you're up upon you have
the bishop there yeah this objectively
still feels very good yeah and here I
for a while I was considering also
Bishop d2 but then the problem was like
there's a lot of stations where he can
play a three also here yeah no I don't
know about here but I mean somewhere I
mean it I mean the point is I was
considering but should be - for a while
but I thought rookie - is maybe not so
bad I spent forever but of course I
missed the detail so I'll show you a
rope before okay Roxy to know he played
95 first yeah 95 yeah 95 Bishop d5 and I
forgot you can play Knight of 4 right
away that's nice yeah yeah no and then
when I played Bishop d5 I saw it I mean
I still spent out of 30 minutes I spend
like half my time you know calculating
this position I couldn't figure out I
mean I really need to work on my
technique apparently based in this game
because it was it was very bad that I
let him back so much into the game where
the very much the result was in doubt
that at some point mm-hmm okay so takes
takes yeah five but at least I think
you're taking a hold of the game again
yes you realize that okay this is still
your only asset yeah I sort of expecting
her to be six here huh I don't know oh
maybe not rugby three right away but
maybe Ruby three is also okay but of
course it looks a bit risky check King
c4 takes on g2 Bishop a4 okay ch3 before
but now you have an active King so yeah
you did get at least something out of it
yeah I mean I don't know at the moment I
was even thinking you know if things go
bad I can even lose this game oh but of
course
no it's unrealistic probably but yeah
the way there's too much the way I was
playing you'll never know in chess right
then he's very resourceful player so
care okay three the ship c6 yeah and
here I think he what did you play here
now that for I think that was just a
blunder because I think
no wait no night of fours okay night of
course okay probably be 5 and then 96 I
think there's a blunder because I think
he thought maybe I can play be 694 he
can play but then I just go at 4
my name is this idea I don't know for a
fact that this is what he missed but it
could be that look probably yes because
be 7 you could take this one
so 94 be 7 you can take no not yeah yeah
exactly a so I think he saw this trick
yeah but I missed
f4 yeah because otherwise in case
instead of 96 if I if he goes rope rope
go back one move okay
yeah instead of 96 if you go through a 4
or something I wasn't at all sure if I'm
winning this because or is it nor is it
this still looks very nice with your
King helping me maybe it was Roque won
first day I don't remember but I yeah
even again b6 they are Oh b1 b1 but now
you can cover Oh
I'm forgetting what the line was but I
thought I saw something that you know
it's not so clear but yeah no no this is
losing yeah yeah so I mean even though
objectively bortnik has defended well
it's still kind of tough to defend this
position yeah I guess
one slip was enough and you're already
winning again yeah although even here I
had to work very hard there's some very
precise calculation I had to do 98% e5
love this Bishop controlling that night
on d8 yes so he played locates a 1 I
thought that's good lose me too
yeah I wanted to make him beef King
before work hmm
King before rugby 1 Bishop e3 but then
he goes like I think what was a king d6
and I wasn't so sure about that
so I can't get murky murky yes so I
thought well I thought the other line is
kind of murky too but I thought it's
more under control for me so I
yeah but rugby - feels like the good
yeah I guess so rook c1 and then if I go
king t3 he goes rook c8 and maybe he's
defending so I went king b5 yeah and I
guess after a 586 of five is important
probably does make sense to start
pushing the h-bond yeah I guess blunder
yes yes probably f5 is just helping this
bishop but again I guess f5 was a
blunder on this part anyways again I
think missing maybe even not sure I'm
not sure I'm not convinced that he
missed King takes the fabric d2 probably
just didn't consider h5 for some reason
on the way I mean I think he was just
trying to create as many practical
chances as I seek I mean he was trying
to I noticed you know based in the way
he was playing he was trying to play in
a way to give me a lot of choices and it
was very unpleasant very often because
he really is a good practical player
like he made me really always consider
like doing a few choices you know and
here again after a 5 I have tons of oh
moves I can play f3 I can play EF I can
play route before it's just but ok
eventually I decided I f king d5 rugby -
I thought I'm winning yeah although I
wasn't a hundred percent sure but and
after king of 5 yeah I was happy to find
rook itsu and King is cut off and then I
go rookie 7 or okie 8 and looks like
here I'm I'm winning still have to do
some precise calculation but now I'm
probably winning yes and again the big
problem that this knife is just stuck
there but I tell you the truth I didn't
see most of it from far ahead and you
know the last calculation was nice
finishing touch that and the end of all
this I have rooty $0.06 once I saw that
then yeah and now you even have shelter
for the king and upon yeah well even if
I didn't s still I know how to win
docena so yeah it's a big win for you
congratulations yeah thank you yeah um I
still very impressed with this night
maneuvers and I think in a practical
game it's not that easy to come up with
the exact bass moves but I think you did
good job I like rugby - Ricky - as well
just if you get the chance to cut the
king and I thought it was a very good
game
like the way you outplayed him in the
mill game I think was pretty impressive
ya know I thought I thought the opening
and early middle game was good I mean I
typically struggle with that part so I
was happy with that but yeah my
technique I definitely something left to
be desired so got to work on that part
so you won this game who you're playing
next Alex a part of tomorrow them so the
Battle of Alexis all right with that so
they also played Alex so yes I you never
run out of Alex opponents all right so
best of luck thank you and hope for the
best
Thank You Dennis hi my name is Ryan
Chester and I'm the development manager
for the Saint Louis chess club I'm here
to tell everyone about a golden
opportunity that we have right now we're
selling golden tickets for $50 a piece
it's a 50-50 raffle $5,000 will go to
the Scholastic chess initiative for the
st. Louis chess club and $5,000 will go
to a lucky winner we're only selling 200
of these and we've already sold many to
grandmasters and all of our commentary
team as well so if you're interested
please call the Chess Club or go to our
website on the homepage and buy a golden
ticket there thank you and good luck
[Music]
you
[Music]
so we are back with Alex under fear that
great to have you finally you came back
with a win
yeah after two bedrooms and just em
tonight one I kind of saw you struggled
a bit in the first rounds with some
tricks they tricked you with a four and
stuff like that but I felt that your
positions were always okay but then you
ran into some tricks in both games
mm-hmm when the first round the thing is
that I tried to play something quite
solid and I got bored at some point yeah
that's what I thought that I have
there's some careless moves I felt that
you were confident that this is a draw
or should be equal and I felt that you
just shuffled pieces and got unlucky
that 8:4 work yeah
so today I threat to play something yes
and you defended the honor of the benoni
you just tied the score in this
tournament today yes lots of Bernoulli's
I don't know this rage it's not that
it's a bad practical choice but I'm not
sure if it's objectively the best all
right so let's start from this position
and please help us go through the key
moments okay I thought actually 94 was a
really strange move because usually what
wants to keep the pieces now yeah and
exchanging one night give more space for
my pieces so I thought after 27 I should
be more or less fine yeah and the only
thing starts to go well and I think b5
was a good move because old banker style
is back here but after Bishop C to us
was really strange I thought you simply
take on c4 when it
it takes before and after Bishop e5 I
thought I thought they should be almost
winning but later after he plays Knight
g5 things it starts to go crazy crazy
and I mean that's not surprising in a
Benoni at all in age 494 it takes 95
yeah here's the thing well I could try
Bishop h6 it was one of the options and
the King G it is possible but I can also
take on aged six that's oh you can stack
the Queen yeah and go with something
like rockefeather just take on age six
and the position these bishops are quite
small yes and after Knight takes if I
ever thought it too should be more or
less over but then I misplace something
eight interesting okay so the comp says
there's something here or rook e1 okay
that I'm not sure I'm convinced what's
going on here I just take well I don't
know I don't feel good about giving away
this pawn yeah okay taken B to probably
and I defend the defend it still very
murky
it was winning after what I played
because I thought it would have Bishop
d3 later Bishop c5 has opened before and
I take six and here I thought they would
go Bishop d3 and probably is the best
move anyway but suddenly I saw that he
has Queen f7 ideas I know know because I
know he has Bishop f6 simply after 95
and when I D 5 ok one here behind vision
at e3 but that is harder to see how kind
of course here takes takes King gate
shade and I could not see how to how to
improve my thesis because my knight has
to be on d5 to the kind of six and my
queen should be on there I can go like
rook e1 something like that and I could
not find a plan yeah your king is
basically stalemated I cannot I cannot
take the bishop what from g5 in the
night from age 6 is also there forever
so should be winning but I start to
panic a bit Pro black and just taken bit
too and
not even convinced yeah it's it's hard
mm-hmm so anyway screened III was played
yeah I thought that this was more self
cut from the I could play in last case
Bishop e6 and just played the end game
which opens up we should be for but now
deadly threat showing it but okay I
don't win so many pause because later he
can take something again and the six
takes takes and you decided to go for
this yeah how that I had two thumbs up
and I said okay enough to play badly
here I think because it should be
similar to in designing it probably I
should just go g5 and they try and don't
care so much about the queenside pounds
yeah just activating your extra two
pawns I try to put everything under
control first but then suddenly my
pieces are all tied to the plate this
night is a little clumsy
always mostly guarding it's not too
active actual rookie 5 Bishop III rook
da Jun okay we played we played some
moves but later at some point he
sacrificed his age 7 pound ha ha and I
thought it would be easier to but after
after rook g7 I had the metaphor I
thought I had g5 okay he cannot take on
g5 because I exchanged on g5 and King b5
is raining
I mean time to go to b3 yeah and after
King before I thought it supposed to be
95 but the problems that he can take
King takes e5 rook c5 King before and I
assume that making is going to be three
and it'll be assuming but you can change
the rooks and go King III and
before kingly talking bid three kings
wanna draw hope not that one
pink see one is slightly stronger yes so
you decided to go king daeso yeah I
realized that I had to try to bring the
king closer to the g5 pawn but and here
friendly I can take the bit you pump
because if he takes once before I change
the rooks no later yeah and you take
take exchange works yeah but well I
thought it was supposed to finish in the
endgame home and then I started to drift
to be drift a bit yeah
but okay this was a good win it's a nice
win a nice win against taco Beyond and
you're back on the table
yeah it's good to be back yeah so how do
you feel after this one four wins in a
row it's coming I lived already ready to
keep crushing ready to keep crushing it
was a bit strange dude because the round
was a bit earlier today but at least we
were in time ago I had time to see the
tiebreaks of the World Cup before I
played did you like the results that you
saw well for the Latino Americans it was
a dark day a heartbreaker yeah well ok
it took place for Brazil it was my
Italian he lost to under a king in first
game he was much much better yeah so
best of luck
you scored your first win never stop we
were playing Mexican I don't know okay
that's the best attitude I don't care
who I'm playing going all-in
yeah all right good luck thank you so
let's take a look at the Quezada Yasir
game that actually finished earlier she
was a big big blow to the chest bra I'm
on Hamilton but a big win for Quezada
Yasir as he gets high on the leaderboard
should be 5 so yasser decides to avoid a
Mons Val tried-and-tested time on of
which is very interesting as he had a
great results here as he once beat the
legendary Alex a sheriff at the black
side so Bishop b5 was played aiming to
have more of a strategic game instead of
a full-blown fight 97 d4 and this is
somewhat different than the usual this
Knight is a little bit clumsy on e7 but
such also the b5 Bishop is out of place
and it's a little bit flimsy there so
Knight takes Queen takes a 6 and
probably taking on d4 was a slightly
inaccurate decision as it brings the
Queen into this whole position of
attacking and getting ready to put some
more pressure on blacks position a 6
Bishop d3 being a 3 and this is the big
issue for blacks position here the Queen
will attack the g7 pawn and why it is
almost already ready to make attacking
moves of 95 and such in c7 F for Bishop
e7 Queen h3 b5 castle Bishop e3 and
while Hambleton is getting ready to
Castle white is already launching an
attack and that's kind of uncomfortable
ok white pieces are very nicely placed
you're back
yeah nice to be back in the chair I had
a little break there as we went through
some interviews and we also have draw
and xeric Petrossian patron zero game oh
yeah that one had fizzled into a
hurricane game a real gang game in the
circle draw well with that I believe we
just have one game remaining but it's a
very important one between Derby Lee and
let's see Malcolm Ian I think who are
both in prime position to become part of
the the leaders in the a group with the
draw they would both join the current
two leaders in Alexander Lenderman
and Dhara spirits but with a win either
one could become the sole leader in the
a group yes oh why don't we take a look
at that game so let's take a quick
glance at it because I don't think that
there's much to look at it white is just
completely winning their belly is going
to win as he's up in exchange g6 is
coming and he's collecting another point
incredible
that puts of a thief at a very very
impressive score here with two and a
half out of three and so he will be the
sole leader in a group so how did
happens happen what went wrong because
last we checked I thought a and yeah I
guess what I wait had some pressure but
I told you maneuvering will commence yes
and white just maneuvered patiently
until black ran out of ideas so Roxy g2
decided to double on the Jeep on as this
rook moved away yes from g8 and he
realized and decided that that these two
rooks already punting lots of pressure
on g7 it's time it still Caleb's nice
Knight ecigs maneuver Annalee the one
that I know caleb is rejoicing for a
good reason because 96 and now they're
big big issues there takes takes there's
not much you can do about it if you push
the pond I'll take H takes and it's over
yeah so takes takes and this is
practically this process trous why make
some consolidating moves but yeah sooner
or later this is a win for white so yeah
this is a huge game for the CIS um yeah
very beautiful technique massif probably
the most on foreign player that we've
seen in the a group every game he just
seems to be playing solidly coming up
with interesting ideas in the opening
getting good positions and then
converting so definitely a favorite to
look at for this big favorite or but
beware there are helixes lurking around
the corner coming up as he's going to
take on another Alex he might get the
chance
to tie for first yeah well why don't we
take a quick look at this golden ticket
promotion once again from the wonderful
Ryan Chester who has some interesting
things to to tell us about this
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
chess club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
well once again very interesting
promotion from Ryan Chester make sure to
get your golden tickets now before it's
too late
they're drawing those once again on
September 30th so time is running out
with that in mind we're coming to the
end of our show here Dennis how about we
take a look at the results for round
three in group a so Alex epi' table did
actually go down to the wonderful ray
Robson who recovered after a rough first
two rounds and Alex Linderman of course
won his game it's olexander bortnik who
we had him here in the studio to talk
about that game massif der by Lee we
very much expect to win his game against
former tournament co-leader fronting all
kuhnian so that would put the safe into
clear first in the a group jordan von
forest drew his game with vara Cobian
and daro drew his game with Ilyas
Spearin so once again the the standings
in Group A are shaking out to be the
Seif in the lead with Darla spirits and
Alec Slenderman chasing close behind
just a half point out of first going to
be a tough tough yet definite it'll be
interesting to watch and why don't we
take a look at the results in the B
group meanwhile Petrosyan drew his game
in Steven xeric Denis Heydrich drew with
Victor McVicker Michalowski around poco
bian lost to Alexander fear Alex with
that very impressive game in the benoni
showing a lot of understanding yeah and
it's important to note that Alex fear
did save the honour of the benoni just
tying the match of the bernoulli's and
it's one and a half one and a half yes
very interesting stuff so yeah circus
Otto Perez of course took down Aman
Hamilton today
and the story of the tournament so far
ejection booyaka three out of three
impressive first in the B group
impressive and so that leaves us today
with one person in clear first one
person in clear second and one person in
clear third in the B group actually that
is Jackson buuck leading with three out
of three
yes sir Quesada Perez in second place
with two and a half out of three and
Steven xeric actually in clear third
place with two out of three these are
the only three players the plus scores
so far this to many players on hot
streaks very exciting stuff and some
very exciting news some sad news as well
I won't be able to join you Dennis
tomorrow tomorrow actually glad to have
Patrick well two-time US Champion
Patrick wolf will be here doing
commentary over the fall chess classic
tomorrow as well as the day after
tomorrow so we will be glad to have him
here in the studio but I will be sad to
see you go Dennis but you'll be coming
back you'll be back I'll be back in
promise all right so be sure to join us
for that coverage tomorrow with a grand
master Patrick wolf starting once again
at 3:30 p.m. and thank you for joining
us today for our coverage of the 2019
ball chest classic
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you